hello I'm Clay Aiken and I'm Reuben
sturbert and we're spilling the E.T
it's been 20 years
since I wiped the floor with you
so play
what was your honest first impression of
me
oh that's not hard I was a little
intimidated by you you just always had
this very confident air about you that a
star
would guide you my way we all realized
you were going to last to the end I'm
the American Idol really I am so what
was your first impression of me my
honest first impression of you
was
this guy is a Mac so I meet clay and he
is in the company of several very
attractive young ladies and I mean by
several I mean like 10 or 12. man he's
the only guy he must
be you know Macadocious
and I learned very quickly that no
that's you know it's not quite it's nice
what it is but still you know you don't
look like a pop star but you got a great
voice yeah weird it's wild what's
something that happened during Idol that
you've never told anyone
oh
[Laughter]
um I came out on idol to myself I had
never
really realized that I was I was gay
until I met someone who worked on the
show and who you know
kind of told you well in a way or
another
you're Flying Without Wings
[Music]
what's your favorite song the icing of
mine my my song Fly me that Wings always
gets me right here I think it gets
everybody else right here too it reminds
everyone of you know how wonderful Idol
was it reminds me of losing
[Laughter]
tell me what you were thinking right at
the moment
that they called my name right before
they were walking out and you had said
to me yeah I remember that was two
things happened that moment one you look
at me and you said can you believe look
at the two of us can you believe the
least likely people to be here and here
we are which have you now like it chills
when I think that and then right after
you said that I turned to my left and
Ryan was going through his cards and I
saw the card that had your name on it
I'm actually staring right at you right
when your name was when your name was
like no you were doing it
but hey bro I knew what was going to
happen and I kind of just wanted to see
the look on your face actually I
remember you said it's you before he
said that you did thank you so much
which judge do you miss the most
I have to I probably Simon is probably
the one who I miss the most what's
astonishing is how handsome this show
has made you I mean seriously we've
gotten a chance to see him over the
years but we don't get to hang out with
any of them
um and as as mean as he was to me I do
look back at some of the things he said
and realize okay he made this particular
very specific comment I need to make
sure I fix it everything about that was
horrible
what I also appreciated about Paula
opposite of Simon was the way that she
cared about how we were after the Lights
and Camera and all the crowds were gone
like she would come and make sure we
were okay I think Paula and Simon were
sort of mom and dad dad was the tough
love mom was making sure you feel good
he's gonna go along with whatever's
being said he wants on the drink
with a couple of your uncle house for
the barbecue you good dog what was the
most memorable comment from the judges
that you remember
honestly my most memorable judge moment
was not from Randy Paul and Simon it was
from Gladys of course and you know I
would have never called myself a velvet
teddy bear of any sort you are and will
probably someday be the world's velvet
teddy bear
that was just such a perfect nickname
what don't you miss
constantly having to worry about getting
cut I remember calling my mom she had my
brother who was still in school and she
had she didn't come out until the top
six she never came and I would call her
every week and say Mom you've got to
come out I'm gonna get cut and you're
not gonna be able to be here and she was
like oh it's fine I think I'm gonna come
out week six I think I'm like Mom that's
five weeks away
which of the newer judges on Idol do you
wish were on our season I'm a Katy Perry
fan
yeah I think that
Simon dictated the energy in the room I
think if Simon was there Lino would
probably be a little bit more tougher
would you ever be a judge on American
Idol I used to say I always wanted to be
a judge absolutely I think now I feel
like I'd be maybe more salmonish than
than they have right now it actually
surprises me that American Idol doesn't
make
you and I permanent like we would be
very excited
mentors we'd be very wise absolutely so
much wisdom I think it would I think it
would do them well especially when
people come up and say what advice do
you have to read on Idol don't try to be
somebody other than who you are don't
try to create this to to hit a high note
that you are just trying to hit for the
purposes of impressing someone be you
Reuben would you vote for me if I ran
for office again I would absolutely vote
for you if you rare for offers again
because I know you actually care about
the things that you
are campaigning about if I had some
folks who were supportive and you know
donated or whatnot but nobody other than
you showed up twice Reuben came and
helped both times and you know how much
if my if my antidepressants weren't
working so hard right now I'd probably
be grinding
two years strong that's why the two are
together again for the appropriately
named 20 the tour now through May 16th
Reuben this is a very important question
go ahead sir how excited are you to
reunite with me for this tour
the excitement can't be
put into words
I mean I am Stevie Wonder says Overjoyed
oh really I really am though I'm excited
about the opportunity to get a chance to
be back on the road with you you're my
brother I wouldn't want to be on tour
with anybody else
other than probably maybe Janet Jackson
I feel a little cheated on if you're
going out with Janet Jackson I'll be
honest you should it's Janet I mean
how's rehearsal been going
wonderfully you've almost taught me how
to dance maybe by the end of the tour
you will have taught me how to dance
[Music]
I think that if I have we have one more
rehearsal
one more I think you'll have it okay
how's it been getting ready for the show
and and teaching being in between
teaching you're teaching at the
University of Tennessee in Chattanooga
if you had to choose one or the other
which would it be teaching or performing
okay
I love
teaching
I really do I enjoy the students I enjoy
it's something to be said about being
around younger versions of yourself and
even when the students are older than I
am because I do have a couple of older
students that are in my class that's the
only ones who know who you are right
they do they actually care
care about what I've actually
accomplished aside like the rest of them
are like man when is my paper due I
don't
care less who you were before you showed
up in this world just give me an a who
would you say is the bigger Diva you or
me I would absolutely say
that
you are
the bigger deal there are several
different kinds of Divas I think that
when it comes to certain aspects of the
production
you are a diva when it comes to certain
things that are required in a dressing
room
well I learned a lot about you and I
learned a lot about you too you're a
fascinating person you are even more
fascinated
I'm Clay Aiken and I'm Reuben Studdard
and that's the T
on ET
[Music]